if you haven't already met my best friend
this is Goldie
she's an almost three year old Hungarian Vizsla
with a little bit of GSP in her
but it feels like just yesterday she was our new baby
so much has changed but also nothing has changed
she's still the exact same personality she was when we met her
Goldie loves to swim, she loves to dig holes
although fortunately for me she's grown out of digging up my garden
and I think her favourite thing in the world to do is run
I'm also fairly confident
she subscribes to that philosophy of
“never let them know your next move”
then our baby turned into a teenager and before I knew it she was all grown up
I'm sure everybody says this about their pup
but Goldie has a heart of pure gold
she's an absolute sweetheart and she doesn't have a bad bone in her body
she's grown up with my three children
so naturally she thinks she might also be one
and we don't have the heart to tell her any different
so Vizsla’s are an interesting breed actually
they come from a hunting background
so she loves to sniff point and retrieve
and apparently they're the fifth fastest dog in the world
and I would believe it
they're a super social breed
she's always making friends with other dogs at the park
and she really loves people
wishes have reputation of being Velcro dogs and I can confirm it's true
and if you wanna make her smile
just give her a cuddle
Goldie gives us her whole heart every single day
and we just wanna give her the best life that we can
and obviously
choosing the right pet food is super important for her overall health
and wellbeing both now and in the future
and I love Hill’s Pet Nutrition
because it's clinically formulated
to deliver the most nutritional benefit for her
and she loves Hill’s because it tastes good
and I know it's good cause when I feed it to her
she stops and thanks me
Also she can be kind of fussy with her food
but she genuinely really likes Hill’s
and by feeding her Hill’s
I know she'll be healthier
stronger and live longer
so we can cuddle for years to come